now speaking about
[ __ ] okay there was a dave england
moment that i wasn't there for but
it happened in europe right was that was
it your [ __ ] and you said
paris in paris romantic paris this is a
kid we did the gumball rally
right and the gumball rally was a
special jackass episode with me
pontius and and knoxville and we went
like racing through 10 different
countries in a big loop through europe
with all these crazy millionaires
it's all kinds of fun uh when we got
back to england where we started
i was done and then they continued on to
shoot in like amsterdam and paris like
uh
all these different places and dave
england was there for
all that filming but if i if i've got
the story right you guys are staying in
a hotel in paris
tremaine's out like drinking and you
think it's funny that
like you're gonna take a [ __ ] and smear
your own [ __ ] all over
tremaine's hotel door handle we were
there to work
and he flew his fiancee now wife laura
in
and they went out on a romantic date and
i thought that was total [ __ ]
so so we were all all of us there
the rest of us are like what can we do
about this and i think it was me and bam
that
went in cahoots on this and just were
like okay
someone needs to take a [ __ ] i don't
think bam was no he was yeah he was
there for sure
yeah he was definitely there was that
yeah and then and then so
anyways long story short i took a [ __ ]
rubbed it all over his uh tremaine's
hotel door room and then when they got
we waited on the outside yeah on the
outside of his hotel door room so when
he gets back from the date they get back
they're gonna go back
home and from around the corner he just
fully just
full squeeze turns yeah yeah we had we
had something like i don't know
maybe not a very good camera but yeah
and not very good angles so
tremaine was like okay you got me good
but the thing was that
at that point then i went out drinking
right
and back then we always shared hotel
rooms we weren't like baller status yet
where we got our own hotel room yeah i
was sharing
my hotel room with gooch one of the
producers and so tremendous like god
dave england's such a dumb ass schmuck
because i'm with gooch who's got a key
to dave england's room
so gooch lets tremaine into dave
england's room
and and uh so tremaine goes in there
he's probably all drunk
too dave's got his suitcase opened up
and tremaine just [ __ ]
pulls out his dick and just pisses into
dave england
pisses on everything in his suitcase and
and that was a step
too far for dave england um
a kid my daughter was on the way like no
like she wasn't born yet but i bought
her a stuffed animal
i don't know it was stupid now i look
like yeah ruby i bought ruby this
stuffed
bunny i remember i put it in there it
was just covered in tremendous piss
and that i don't know that i guess it
was just the whole thing like all my
stuff was covered in piss and i was
drunk
and our next stop was amsterdam the next
morning oh we're going straight to
amsterdam
so i'm like well [ __ ] that i called the
hotel it was dirty during spring break
didn't she call the airline i called
everybody i canceled their flight
everybody's
flights i guess all the hotel
reservations everybody everyone else
that we were filming with the rest
and i just i flew back home in the
middle of the night and canceled
everybody's [ __ ] for their like next
like real dick
in my bag of my daughter's stuffed
animal that's why
[ __ ] dude in here i forgot
dude we came out here to work man
he went to dinner
with his future wife he went to dinner
so he did a meal goddammit this whole
trip
yeah when did they learn what happened
like um
yeah well they woke up the next day they
went to the airport to get their flight
they're like
you canceled the fight and then they're
like they got somehow got another flight
got to the
to amsterdam at during spring break and
they're like you don't have a hotel room
so they got pretty mad at me i was in
all this yeah didn't you get fired
that's funny dude guess what i have
the number 30 ranked hot sauce on all of
amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude